In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 15th, on which we commemorate St. Jerome.
Our Holy Father Jerome was born into a Christian family in 347, in St. John, in Dalmatia, near
Lubljana, in present-day Slovenia.
At the age of 12, he was sent to Rome to study with the famous Gramarian Donatus, who aroused
in him the love of rhetoric, with which all his works are impregnated.
The young boy, endowed with an ardent temperament and formidable memory, studied with ardor
and showed an insatiable desire for knowledge.
Frequent visits to the tombs of the martyrs in the catacombs inspired him with a measureless
zeal for Christ.
But carried away by the company he kept, his youth was disordered and stormy, and he later
bitterly regretted this.
At about the age of 20, shortly after having received baptism, he left Rome for trial.
At that time, the emperor's residence, intending to make a career in the administration.
It was there that he felt the irresistible call of God, to leave everything, for his service.
He then went to Aculea, where he, with his friend and fellow-disciple Rufinos, joined a circle
of clergy and layfolk who were giving themselves to devout meditation, and formed, as he said,
a choir of the blessed.
From that time on to the ascetic life with all the ardor of a character that knew no compromise,
he decided to follow an example of Abraham, the patriarch, and all who exiled themselves
for the love of God, and travel to the east.
Arriving in Antioch, he spent lent, infasting, and deciduous meditation on the prophets,
reflection that he adorned, however, with the reading of classic writers, seized by a violent
fever in the middle of the fast, and being at the point of death, he was enraptured in spirit,
and saw himself appearing before the judgment seat of God.
When he stated that he was a Christian, the judge replied,
you lie, you are a Ciceroan, not a Christian, and ordered that he be beaten with rods.
Whipped thus by his conscience, Jerome made the following oath,
Lord, if ever I possess profane books or read them, I will have denied thee.
From that time on he devoted himself exclusively to the reading of the Holy Scripture, taking
counsel of no one, he buried himself in the desert of Calses, southwest of Antioch, with
the desire of imitating St. Anthony's struggles in 375, but he had overestimated his strength,
and in spite of the fasts and mortifications that he inflicted on himself, he found himself
terribly tempted by thoughts and memories of his past life.
While exhausting his body by asceticism being burned by the sun and living among scorpions
and wild beasts, he imagined himself in the lap of delights of Rome, surrounded by abandoned,
young women.
To fight Asidia, he perfected his knowledge of Greek, learned Hebrew and Aramaic with a great
struggle, and kept up a correspondence with his friends in Aculea.
In these trials God gave him heavenly consolations, but he had nevertheless to leave the desert,
whose peace was shattered by the monks quarreling about the schism in the Church of Antioch.
Sympathetic toward Paulinos' party, Jerome appealed to Pope Damasus I, asking him to cut
short the debate, but receiving no reply.
He then went to Antioch, where having been ordained priest by Paulinos, despite his reservations,
he pursued his biblical studies with the greatly learned Apolineris of Laudicea, filtering
out what there was in his teaching that did not conform to orthodoxy.
When attracted by St. Gregory the Theologian's reputation for eloquence and holiness, he
left for Constantinople, where he spent three years in St. Gregory's school, discovering
with admiration the works of origin which he began to translate.
After St. Gregory's retirement, he was invited by Paulinos of Antioch and St. Epiphanios to
accompany them to the Council of Rome in 382.
During the sessions, Pope Damasus noticed Jerome's rare talents, and at the end of the
Council kept him with him as his secretary.
The great hierarchy knew how to stimulate his spirit with questions on the difficult
passages of the scriptures, and charged him with the revision of the Latin translation
of the Gospels, comparing it with the original Greek.
His reputation as an exegete led him to become the spiritual guide of a group of noble
and devout women, brought together by St. Marcella in the Aventinos Palace.
She organized regular talks in the course of which Jerome adorned his explanations of the
sacred text and his courses in Hebrew, with incensed exhortations to the ascetic life.
He wrote to St. Ostukium, the very young daughter of St. Paula, be a knight-cricut, bathe your
bed every night, soak it in tears, keep vigil, and become like a lone sparrow.
But his indomitable zeal, both in exalting the ascetic life, and in reproving the conduct
of worldly clergy, earned him many adversaries, who accused him of condemning marriage, and
who, after the death of Damasus in 384, circulated such calamities against him that he was forced
to leave Rome in 385.
He found Paula and her daughter, Ostukium, in Antioch, and undertook a long pilgrimage
with them, both to the Holy Land and to Egypt, to the desert fathers.
At the end of this round tour, Jerome following the example of St. Melania, the elder, and her
friend Rufinas, on the mount of olives, settled in Bethlehem, and founded two monasteries
near the Church of the Nativity, one for monks, and the other for St. Paula, and the devout women
who had followed her in 389.
Watching over the organization of the two communities, he then wrote for them the lives of St.
Paul of Thebes, St. Illadion, and St. Malkus.
He gave daily commentaries on the scripture to St. Paula and her disciples, and also received
many pilgrims who came to venerate the grotto of the Nativity and drink the source of his
learning.
But it was, above all, there, that he consecrated himself to the immense work of translating
the Holy Scriptures and their commentaries, inspired by Origen's method, but leaving
a greater place to literal interpretation.
He declared, not to know the Scriptures is not to know Christ.
In his concern to return to the exactness of the original text, drove him to undertake
the translation of the whole Old Testament from the Hebrew, a colossal task that he completed
after fifteen years of unremitting work in 405.
Alongside these works of exegesis, his impetuous character did not allow him to keep silence
on contemporary ecclesiastical affairs, and it was with the same zest that he had put
into the struggle with the passions in the desert that he engaged in the battle in defense
of the truth against the heretics.
In spite of his admiration for Origen, he supported St. Epiphanios, in his tumultuous campaign
against the disciples of the great Alexandrian doctor, and quarreled with his friend Rufinus
and his bishop John of Jerusalem.
The controversy deepened when Epiphanios decided to ordain Jerome's brother Paulinean to serve
the monasteries in Bethlehem.
John protested against this anti-canonical encroaching on his jurisdiction, and forbade
access to the Basilica of the Nativity to Jerome and his disciples.
They, however, came to a compromise through the intervention of Thelfelus of Alexandria
in 396, but two years later, the quarrel flared up again at the time of Rufinus' translation
of Origen's treaties on principles.
Jerome immediately reposted with the translation exposing the whole of Origen's heresy and
continued his polemic against his erstwhile friend until after the latter's death.
He influxed into Bethlehem of crowds of refugees from the west after the sack of Rome by the
barbarians in 410, constrained him to put himself at their service, and to do rather than
write about holy things.
But Jerome did not at night abate his work of exegesis and polemics.
He wrote, in particular, against the Pelagians, who in reprisal attacked the monastery in Bethlehem
and left the buildings in ruin in 416.
This Latin community isolated in the east and in decline from that time had little hope
of a future, and Saint Jerome's death, which came about on the 30th of September in the
year 420, it soon disappeared.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.